now we have just completed the first
step we have divided by the given factor
so where can we go from here well I'm
going to use this piece of information
let's get some space over here now we're
going to go from here to a complete
factorization so I want you to remember
this part probably is worth writing now
that may be off on the same the answer 0
remainder 0 I think it's helpful because
you will often have remainders and it's
important to identify you do have a
remainder its 0
ok can you guys help me out let's just
do a simple numerical one can you help
me divide this what's what's my first
thing I'm gonna write down can't go into
one so there the next thing it goes once
into that and I get seven and then I get
three carry down the 0 how many times
four times four times that is that and
that's why I get a remainder of two okay
now the reason why we're just going
through that is because we can make a
statement out of this is about division
but I can make a statement about
multiplication that's gonna be very
useful for my polynomial over here
okay the statement about multiplication
maybe you remember it is 100 you can
write it as how many lots of seven
fourteen of them write 14 lots of seven
and then there's also a remainder
hanging around right remember that now I
can make a similar statement over here
with this polynomial arranging the
divisor dividend quotient and remainder
okay here's the way we're going to write
it down this color we start by saying
the dividend that's the 100 the thing
that was being divided out right it was
X cubed minus 7x minus six remember that
right that was why I can now break that
into see this part here I can break it
into the two factors that I've just
found right those two factors were X
plus 1 and have a look have a look this
is the question right x squared minus X
minus six x squared minus X minus 6 and
then just like here I add the remainder
if there is one what is the remainder
this case is plus zero so I'm just gonna
not write that down doesn't change
things okay now this is good because
what you've got over here is a quadratic
and you guys are very good at
factorizing these without any long
algorithms can someone tell me the pair
of numbers I'm after minus 3 and plus 2
right so I'm just gonna straight away go
X minus 3 X plus 2 are you happy with
that thumbs up so this was a long step
right that first step is hard but then
when you get a quadratic you're like
cool I can always go on autopilot here
you've just completed the factorization
so now we're ready to complete this
would you please underneath this draw a
set of axes for me okay now what was the
point of factorizing why is factorizing
helpful for if I'm trying to graph what
information is easy to read off the
factorized form the roots are what I are
easy for me to see right Julie go ahead
and tell me it's enough what the what do
you think the more time negative 1 plus
3 and negative 2 so these are the 3
roots that I read off of the factor so
I'm going to take those 3 roots and I'm
just going to plot them on to my
Cartesian plane here so let's chuck a
negative 1 negative 2 0 1 2 3 ok so this
is what it looks like are you kind of
happy with that look alright so I know
I'm going to pass through these now you
don't need to draw this but I'm going to
have either one of these or one of these
either one of those shapes could pass
through all three of those points how do
I know which one it is is it going to
sort of go downward or is it going to go
upward what do you see
ok so we can think about this two ways
right number one it shall we're saying
if I multiply these three things
together they're all positive right so
you're gonna get something really
positive as you go further and further
to the right okay
and that works totally fine with me
another way you can think about it is
just to put a number in write a number
like a hundred if you put a hundred in
here that's gonna be like what's a
hundred times a hundred times a hundred
that's like a million right a million
taking away some other small stuff so
this is a really big positive number you
following with me so I know I'm going to
be this guy not the other one okay so
I'm heading up in the right hand side
now I need to join them together so I'm
going to do this I think my shape is
going to look roughly like that what do
you reckon you okay with that do you
have a question
uh-huh now one of the things you'll
notice is I deliberately did not place
the y-intercept until I had done this it
is exactly at negative six and I'm going
to therefore label this as negative six
I'm gonna tell you why why I did I'm
doing to tell you now why I didn't put
that on earlier okay do you have a
question is record how'd I get which
shape do you mean when I was having a
look at these guys like how did I come
up with these so I'm thinking of oh how
did I go from from this into that my
question to you would be where else
could it possibly go in order to make
sure I fit through these three points
right so just try and start to draw
something right that fits this basic
overall shape and see if you could fit
it if you wanted to if you wanted to put
a few extra steps in you could use some
of the techniques we've developed over
the last little while for instance do
you remember when we used to look at
regions like when we'd say the sign R
plus or minus that kind of thing what I
could do is I could graph one two three
factors let me show you what it looks
like okay it does take longer but it
gives you a limo certainty of what the
shape is X plus one that's gonna look
roughly like this X plus two like this
and X minus three is going to be down
lower okay these three green lines they
each represent one of these three
factors okay and then I'm gonna multiply
together
do you member when you're doing
multiplication of functions together
would give you your
Graff we didn't even tell you what the
equations when we said hey multiply
these together right when you have a
look at that will make us a bit longer
who you when you have a look at the
leftmost part of this graph this part
over here you've got one two three
things that are all negative when you
multiply three negative things
what will the sign of the add subbu
it'll be negative right negative times
30 times negative two of them will
cancel leave you with one negative right
so I'm negative down here what about
when you hop over one step to the left
how about between here and here you've
got negative negative positive what
happens when you might apply them
together positive do you see this is
just going to go up and then down and
then up and then down because here
you've got negative positive positive
together that gives you negative and
last one for completeness okay three
positives I already knew the first thing
that we worked out from the
factorization was I knew where these
intercepts were and now I just need to
go through those orange areas and those
blue dots and find a curve that fits all
of them and this is the one that does
that does that make sense you're
starting it to be a bit more intuition
for once you do a few more of these as
you'll say because all cubics share a
lot of characteristics in common
now just to come back to this idea of
negative six right the reason I didn't
put it on earlier was if I had like
measured out of place and I went like oh
I think this is the one two three four
five six and placed it somewhere right
ironically it's actually much harder to
do an accurate graph when you've got
like a specific spot you have to hit did
you notice how quickly I just sort of
went wee and I did a graph and it didn't
have to be super precise in a variety of
ways for example I don't know where
these two points are but that's because
we're not going to get to that until
later on in the year when I've got
calculus is a different topic under my
belt so you don't need to know where
they are at this point this overall
shape the curvature the intercepts
that's all we need so I'm actually gonna
put on afterwards by the way how do we
know is negative six how did you look at
it just sayin where's negative six on
the board key see
it's at the end of the um polynomial is
it it you can see that if I put in x
equals zero that's how you usually find
a y-intercepts right what happens to the
X cubed term if X equal zero just
becomes zero what about this guy it's
just zero so you just get left with the
constant term there's your graph are you
happy with that can I ask you guys to
have a look at number two I'm not going
to hold your hand for this division but
once you get to that division there's
something different about question 2
versus question 1 it's why I gave it to
you not just going to be more the same
but I would like you to practice going
through that division without my help I
reckon you guys can have it go or if you
are struggle a little bit course every
what individually give you hint okay